the draft for today the things we want
to see happen tonight in round one chris
here's your trivia question this is the
first time the jaguars are ever
holding the first overall pick in the
draft however three prior times they
have taken
the second selection in the draft name
two of the players that the jaguars have
selected
at number two overall i i mean i saw
this question a few like a minute ago
and this is i i
so all right tony bacelli is number one
right
yes now this is where i i i cannot don't
do this yet okay don't put the horn this
is not my answer
i know because i just start throwing out
names and hope to get one well no i mean
i'm tossing around like i'm pretty sure
jaylen ramsey was after two blake
bortles was two or three
and i want to say he was three and i
just can't think of who else would be
number two all right i'm gonna do this
one here we go i'm gonna say john no it
wasn't him john henderson i'm wrong
that's not nope
kevin hardy in 1996
joel in 2013.
i wouldn't have thought it yeah man
totally forgot about luke joko out of
texas a m holy cow yep so all right it
came down to eric fisher luke joko the
two tackles because it was presumed to
be luke jokel
and then the chiefs went eric fisher
instead and uh both currently out of the
league but fischer has a chance to be
back in he had a torn achilles last year
and the chiefs cut him all right things
that we want to see tonight and god this
can go in so many different directions
here's the first thing i'd like to see
for a variety of reasons yeah let's
let's not boo roger goodell that's
played out yeah good luck played out
it's i know but but like cleveland
this is
last year nobody had the draft last year
everybody was stuck at home remember
last year they had that kind of
goofy attempted self-awareness where the
fans booed goodell and it was all one
big joke and i think it's played out i
think it's over let's not boo the
commissioner it's the commissioner
who has made the draft into a traveling
road show even though it kind of
happened by accident the hammer lock at
radio city music hall ended years ago it
was the commissioner who wanted to take
it city to city cleveland be positive be
happy that you have the draft let's not
boo the commissioner tonight i know that
i know it's a pipe dream right but i
hope i just feel like that window is
closed yeah i'm with you i'm i'm sick of
seeing that crap too i am
he does a ton of good for the league he
really has he's been an incredible
commissioner that way i'm sick of the
booing
of roger goodell or the booing of any
owner of a franchise that hasn't won
like five championships if you don't win
five championships then you don't get
booed as an owner but everybody else
gets booed i'm just like why because
they're rich or powerful they just
that's their that's our line for booing
people now i don't know um all right
well
this is a pretty easy first pick for me
all right what do i want to see okay
i want to see
the minnesota vikings miss a pick
and i get to talk about it and have a
lot of fun with you tomorrow morning on
the show because i'm working tomorrow
mike this damn five-day schedule ain't
cool
i don't like it the hell was that crap
damn this is really a thursday on a
thursday this stinks i hate it but that
again and that's not personal to rick
spielman or mike zimmer any of you guys
i don't wish that on you i'm just
wishing it on
that guy that guy right there i just
want to see him go through the torment
and everything like that so that's what
i want to see more than anything tonight
the vikings miss a pick
you know i'm gonna pivot then away from
what my next pick was going to be it was
going to be i want to see the 49ers take
justin fields at number three just
because that sets the stage for chaos
thereafter especially as it relates to
the destination of mack jones but based
on what you said earlier and i'm not
going to let you forget it i want the
patriots to draft justin field because
as you said earlier and we can play the
tape back any time if the patriots end
up with justin fields in any way shape
or form
you are wearing a t-shirt tomorrow that
we will not be able to tell that you
have a t-shirt on
because the t-shirt will be every bit as
white as the skin that is hiding under
your dress shirt today uh yup that's
right that's right you better hope that
happens i i i will have my white tank
top on as i do always underneath these
shirts and i'll do it i'll have my gun
showing and everything so that will be
really embarrassing i hope i don't uh
hope that doesn't happen all right
not just chris carter ripping off his
dress shirt with his undershirt on like
he did during a come on man segment no
no this is a full season two hours oh
t-shirt you want to i thought i said
just the full segment i thought that's
what i was okay well i think segment is
all in i think we don't want to make
everybody turn the channel on the show
all right let's do seg one right it's
got to be seg one cause segue one's
gonna be extra long tomorrow so yeah
right the show so i'll be wearing it for
40 minutes tomorrow sun's out gun's out
all right all right my next one we kind
of just talked about this a little bit
but
oh can we get him a wide receiver
in round one ever
oh aaron rodgers give him some help i
want to see the freaking packers take a
wide receiver take a weapon take
somebody that scares the defense and let
like give some roger some gifts that's
what i want to see yeah i love aaron
rodgers he's the best quarterback of all
time he's been done wrong by the
organization and i'm just sick of it i
can't take it so i want to see them get
him a real difference maker on that side
of the ball to where it's just not
always on him to have to play the most
perfect game ever for them to win every
sunday i'm so sick of that crap so
yes uh packers draft of receiver
you're giving me an idea because this
year they've got 13 well it's down to 12
now because caleb farley's not there and
i don't know whether they backfilled his
spot with someone else but they had 13
scheduled to be at the draft yeah 45
prospects
with
setups in their home where they can
participate virtually and we'll see them
there like we did last year right why
not set up some veteran players select
veteran players with cameras in their
homes
so we can see their reaction to their
team's pick i mean they could watch
aaron rodgers first of all watching
jeopardy and critiquing anderson cooper
that would be awesome and then he turns
it over to the draft he's sitting there
with scotch if it's good tequila if it's
bad yeah and we see
as we creep toward the packers pick
how's he gonna react wouldn't that be
great oh that would be amazing i'd be
all for that i really would be it would
be great the only thing is just yes
you'd have to you'd have to go for the
superstar players in the draft because
you know the guys that aren't superstars
there's a good chance that somebody gets
drafted at your position and it's going
to be not a great reaction on tv who
knows what happens then you might have
four letter words and a lot of other
things go on but uh that would be fun
like we love that lamar video he made
back in the day remember when they
drafted hollywood brown and how excited
he was walking around his living room or
whatever that is great tv i love seeing
that stuff but it's not about it miller
when the broncos drafted bradley chubb
exactly how excited he was right exactly
yeah i would like to see that
all right next one for me i want to see
the browns trade up we talked earlier
this week about how they can't trade
down
out of the round their fans would not
like that at all i think the burst of
excitement that would happen
at the draft location
if the commissioner walks to the podium
and says we have a trade the browns are
now on the clock i i think that's the
kind of moment that we tune in for for
these drafts yeah get those browns fans
excited there's not going to be nearly
as many people as we've seen at past
drafts but
it will get loud it will get raucous it
will get very exciting if the browns
trade up tonight definitely would i mean
yes you might hear the whole roar of the
city just in the background with that
you need to forget the people at the
draft but that's a good one by you i
didn't think about anything brown
centric that way that would be fun to
watch and just see the excitement and
everybody we know cleveland lives and
dies with that football team and they
really got something to live for right
now it's pretty cool um
all right i'm gonna go to one that just
kind of hits home for me personally
i wanna see are you just asking me what
i wanna see i wanna see jalen phillips
and caleb farley go in the top 20.
that's what i want to see you know i i
don't know i guess i have a soft spot in
my heart for guys that are super super
talented and yeah they've had some bad
breaks but like jalen phillips a pass
rusher from the miami hurricanes caleb
farley from virginia tech are no doubt
top five players in the draft and if
they don't have medical issues they are
top five picks in this draft i i hate to
see
great talents like that fall right
because of some mishaps or bad luck or
whatever it may be so i'm rooting for
them to not fall too far
and uh you know kind of have a get get
their wish that way
all right uh those are the things that
we would like to see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports